- [Gary] All right, DRock.
We have to get up
in like five minutes.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
- It's me and DRock
headed to JFK, Lufthansa,
connecting in Germany.
Headed to Romania for
what, like eight hours?
- Yeah.
- Is that the actual number?
- [DRock] No, it's
more like 10 or 12.
- 10 or 12 hours in
Romania and then back
and we're just literally
sitting here like trying
to debate like, let's make a
different kind of DailyVee.
So we'll see what we
come up with right now
and you will see it,
pressure's on now.
We're on the record.
- Now we have to.
("Simply" by EHMJI)
- Yeah, I'm in Romania.
Bucharest,
beautiful city.
Maybe you'll get
some drone footage, DRock.
Been on a weird
sleeping pattern,
two hours here, two hours there.
Heading over to the main
venue now for the keynote.
I'm just a bit behind,
which is fine.
I just looked at another, hello.
- [Man] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm feeling well,
what about you?
- Very good.
- I came from
Brasov just to see you.
- Thank you.
- And DRock.
- And would you
please take a photo with me?
- Of course, of course.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Awesome, my friend.
No problem, I'm glad we met.
- Sorry but you made my day.
I'm glad we made it.
- And you too, DRock.
- [Gary] Awesome man, thank you.
- Good luck.
- Thank you, take care.
Right and so,
here we are.
It's gorgeous, first of all.
Second of all, I'm excited.
Energy is there.
I'm trying to find mine.
When I sleep like
two hours at a time
over 24 hours,
it's just awkward.
It's awkward, DRock.
- [DRock] I get it.
- You know?
("Simply" by EHMJI)
You must love
this light, DRock.
- [DRock] I know.
- This is real life, real light.
For me, I'm driven by gratitude.
I'm just thankful
that I get to play my game.
I love the process
much more than the riches.
I've never been
somebody who wanted the cars
or the shoes or
the house or the plane.
For me, I just wanted
to be the best at the game
and so I feel like I'm
a purebred entrepreneur
and so just waking
up to play the game,
to put on the jersey,
to get on the field,
that's what drives me.
Not yet, but I'm getting closer.
Building up.
It's like rebooting a machine.
- [Announcer] The
hottest speaker in the world,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(electronic music)
(audience applause and cheering)
- Smoke is fuckin' cool.
(audience laughter)
Thank you so much, I'm very,
very excited to be
here this afternoon.
("Simply" by EHMJI)
But I spend more time on HR.
than anything else I do.
More than sales,
more than being GaryVee,
more than selling,
more than anything,
more than the product services.
The majority of my
time is spent on H.R.
I landed here, I took
a two hour nap right now,
I woke up, for
the 30 minutes before
I got here, it was all HR.
This person this, this
person's feelings, that.
This person's mother passed
away which is devastating.
Like what are we
gonna do, like all HR.
HR, HR, HR, HR.
The world is human.
The people are the game.
So, actions
backing up the words.
- Because there's a lot
of people who are good people
and fucking
awesome at what they do.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
Here's what I would do.
I would probably use
Facebook very aggressively
against the
advertising capability
of employees of organizations
or against individuals that
you know you're targeting.
And what I would do
if I were you actually
is I would go into
the events business.
Let me explain
what I mean by that.
Based on what
I'm hearing from you,
I would probably use social
media and digital advertising
and heck, above the
line traditional advertising
as a gateway drug
to private dinners
and mini conferences.
What I love about
B2B businesses,
especially when
it's big decisions,
big dollars,
small groups of people
is I wanna get them in.
So for me, the wine tasting
or conference
that look like this
for all the mayors
and entrepreneurs
and businesspeople
once a quarter,
once a year, using.
One of the things we've done
for very big B2B plays
that are more
infrastructure plays like that
is we've used
Facebook to be an invitation
to a very premium event.
Got them there and you know,
after a little bit
of RosÊ from Slavonia.
(laughter)
Alcohol is an incredible
gateway drug to a big deal.
- [Man 2] So you mean
use it just as a
way to get in contact with them,
to get in touch with them?
- [Gary] And back to the great
statement that was said here,
if you're
offering them an exclusive
first 25 people that register
go to this wonderful place
with this wonderful meal
with this wonderful event
or speaker or performance,
they just come in droves.
And we've been able
to very successfully,
'cause of
Facebook ads, underpriced,
we've been able to
get small private events.
We're selling five, 10,
15 million dollar apartments
on Facebook by targeting
high net worth individuals,
inviting them
to high end dinners
and then the company
takes over and closes
two or three of them.
- [Man 2] Does this
happen only locally,
like in their cities or you
call them into a different city
like a few
hundred kilometers away?
- [Gary] So, I would tell
you that it depends
on the creative of
the evening, right?
If you get the most
famous fuckin' person on Earth,
people will go anywhere, right?
So I think you have to map
what are you
offering them, right?
If you're pouring
1982 first growth Bordeaux,
they may go a
little further, you know?
I think you've gotta figure out
what the value prop is
compared to the distance
and make it worth
their while to come.
It's just a value exchange.
51/49, if you create.
But what's really
great is you could go big.
I like small.
I like the eight
person dinner series
once every two weeks.
Get them into you confine.
Bring them value.
You know those mayors,
those entrepreneurs,
they have similar themes
on things they care about.
Bring content or a speaker or
a performance or information
that's valuable
to them holistically.
Even if it's about tax reform,
has nothing to do
with your stadium building
but you brought them
value, you're the host,
you're there and away you go.
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- [Announcer] Ladies
and gentlemen,
put your hands
together for Gary Vaynerchuk!
("Simply" by EHMJI)
- Hey man, how are you?
- You're the best.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- A few words for Romanian
people who watching you.
- One life baby, don't
fucking waste it, hustle!
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Take care, buh-bye.
So you know,
I'm fortunate enough
that I get to do this a lot.
A lot of cities,
a lot of conferences
every year for the
last seven, eight years.
The energy, the
warmth, the desire.
You know, maybe it's my emotion
of being born in Eastern Europe,
kind of coming
home-ish to that area.
- [Man 3] So we really have to
focus on your strength.
That's what you said.
But is it only one strength?
There is this theory
with the love category.
Like you're good at
one or two or three things.
- I do think depending
on your natural strengths
is the best way.
And I do think some people have
one, two, three, four skills
so I'm comfortable with that.
My bigger thing is that,
I think people
waste time and energy
dwelling on what
they're not good at.
Or putting all their energy
on getting a little bit better
at something that
will never happen.
So for me, I don't care if
it's one two or three things,
I just care that
it's actually about things
that you're actually good at,
not things you
wish you were good at.
- [Gary] You guys
are from the U.S.?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's awesome,
where you going?
- I'm going to UPenn.
- [Gary] Amazing. Amazing.
I'll tell you, people.
There's nothing you're
going to learn in class
that's going to matter.
You guys are
going to good schools.
It's not gonna matter.
I go to Stanford,
and Harvard, and Wharton.
I go all over the place.
All the curriculum is outdated.
It's outdated, and these are
the best schools in the world.
But your roommate, the
people you hangout with.
When you go to
those kind of schools,
they have very interesting
families and relationships.
It's all relationship.
All of it, all of it,
all of it, all of it, all of it.
Got it?
- Thank you.
Can you make it a video too?
- Yeah, DRock,
you're in it right now.
(laughs)
- Can we take picture?
- Sure, of course.
("Simply" by EHMJI)
Look, I think it comes
down to personal stuff.
So you're asking to
drop out of university?
- No, no.
- Oh you're gonna go?
Are you gonna go to university?
- Yeah.
- Love it.
So listen, man,
I think all the skills
in trading,
in bitcoin, that arbitrage,
that eye for the vig,
that plays out.
I'll tell you the one thing,
is if you have the ability to
be good at trading that way
your ability to trade
real life is even greater.
So before you can only
settle for the trading math,
figure out if you
can trade culture.
No, I get it, I get it.
But there's a difference
between math skills and trading.
Do you understand?
Of course you do, you did it.
I understand that.
So I would just say to,
like, try a lot of shit,
and figure out what
the fuck you're good at
before you settle
into this makes me money.
So many kids who have talent,
are fucking just
settling on the corner,
krypto without realizing they
can be making tens of millions
instead of tens of thousands.
Try shit, your
biggest advantage is time.
With everyone I got in my life,
I fucking trade all of
it in the 70s, all of it.
24 years, fucking
take it right now.
Take advantage of that.
Alright, brother.
- And I have this guy over here
so I can have accountability
So thank you Gary for this.
- My pleasure.
Asked a great question,
sorry to interrupt you,
he asked a great
question, I said,
"Give your
manifesto to the world."
He's got the experience,
he's actually done it,
I'm very proud of you
for doing this, go ahead.
- Hi, hi.
- So just to work on logistics
to get to the VIP dinner,
but super successful good talk.
DRock made a rare
appearance on stage.
- [DRock] Rare.
- Hey DRock.
Here ya go.
(audience applause)
Funny thing is when you
like being behind the camera,
you don't like
being in front of it.
Hold on, I'ma film you.
Go ahead, answer the question.
(audience laughs)
Oh, looking good
DRock, good, good.
That was super exciting.
Some days you
gotta grind through.
on two or three hours sleep.
- But how was your experience?
- You did a great job, man.
I'm very impressed.
I do a lot of these.
I'm now very much
looking forward to Singapore.
I know it's
already in good shape.
("Simply" by EHMJI)
Guys, DRock says
this is the golden hour.
Everything is magical and sunny.
I'm very happy for you DRock.
The lighting here,
the golden hour.
Hello, how are you?
- Amazed, the appointment today
was very, very --
- You enjoyed it?
- Yeah, it was very cool man.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you finally.
(crosstalk)
- Entrepreneurship has
been painted
in a place where
it's just not true.
It's very hard, it's lonely,
it's 99% don't succeed.
It's been given a false position
and it's dangerous.
Being a media
player producing content,
it's like creating the honey,
the bees come to you.
I didn't realize this
about myself until last--
last year, I was
raising $150 million fund
and I stopped and
gave back $45,000,000
that I had raised already.
Gave it back.
- [Man 4] Why is that?
- Because I realized I
didn't like asking for money,
I don't like selling.
- [Man 4] I don't
like selling either.
- I don't like selling.
- [Woman] You
don't like selling?
- I know, that's
a very weird thing.
- [Woman] But you're good at it.
- I figured out
why I'm good at it.
I'm very good at it
because I don't sell.
- [Man 4] You say the truth.
- I let it come to me.
So when I had to go and say,
do you want to
give me $10,000,00?
I'll invest it and you'll
get like, you know,
I didn't like the process.
I didn't like, notice how
I said I even felt guilt
or responsibility to pay
back my parents, my parents.
So I was sitting
there and I said,
wait a minute, if I fail,
and I was already
getting uncomfortable
with fake entrepreneurs
and getting harder to invest.
When I invested what I invested,
the only people that were
building startup companies
on Web 2.0 were really pure.
You know, they
were in it for in it.
It was 10 years ago.
Now all the business
people are in it, like me.
So I was already a
little uncomfortable
that I was going into a
difficult market to invest it.
But when I realized, oh my god,
if I lose this money,
I'm gonna pay everybody back.
It made no sense to do it.
I could feel it in my body
that if I was to
lose your $10,000,000,
that I would have had
to, for my own feelings,
give it back.
- [Man 4] You would feel the--
- I couldn't, I don't know,
the reason I think
I'm a nice person
is because of the following:
I wouldn't know how to act
if I know I did
something bad to him.
Like, the thought, to
go somewhere in public
and know I did
something wrong to him,
I don't have that gear.
I'm political, I'm a salesman,
I'm a brander,
I've got schpiel, I shmooze.
I don't have the ability to
do something wrong
and make pretend that I didn't.
("Exjets" by Kwesi)
No such thing as
half-pregnant, right?
So that's what I try to
tell my change agent friends.
I say, look, I love that
you care about your company
so much that you
want to help it change,
so here's my recommendation.
Have a back-up plan
'cause then you have
the audacity to be achieving.
The reason I've done
so well is I won't waiver.
And I lose tons of,
I said it today.
I could have
such a bigger business
if I was just,
if I just accepted
programmatic banner ad buying,
if I just accepted that,
I would do $100 million
more revenue a year.
We lose pitches
constantly because I will not
let them do
banner ads on the web
and they then don't pick us.
All-in, right?
Because when
you're half-pregnant,
they have things to
poke and prod at you, right?
If you're being selective,
they can write you off
because you've
wavered in other areas.
So then you're
not a change agent.
It's hard, it's why so
people can make it happen.
You've gotta have the leverage.
I need to go somewhere quiet.
- [Man 5] Okay,
okay, come with me.
Come with me.
- Thanks guys.
I'll be back.
("Exjets" by Kwesi)
Yeah, this will work.
This will work.
DRock, these classic, you know,
just a classic Romanian lake,
business call scene.
You're pumped, right?
We may have to go
with the classic episode.
May have to show that first.
Yeah, I think we should.
So we're just
literally sitting here,
like trying to debate,
like let's make a
different kind of daily video.
Because we need that
when it's not, you know?
Pressure's on now.
We're on the record.
- [DRock] Now we have to.
- Now we have to.
Did you just fall?
(audience laughter)
Did you just trip?
Let me tell you a story
of something that is subjective,
and something that is not.
Here is something
that is subjective.
The quality of the content.
You make something,
and you have a client,
and they go,
"Rubbish," or "Phenomenal."
You both say it's
phenomenal, you know this.
You put it out, and
it doesn't do anything.
I've made videos, me
and DRock, back over like,
"This is gonna fucking kill."
And then nothing happens.
Creative, the
quality of the product,
is subjective
until it sees the world.
It just shows that
that's what you were doing.
I would say one of the
biggest things that happened
in my career was DailyVee.
It showed people that I was
actually working that hard
and there was
no longer a debate.
Was I just saying
hustle, or was I doing it?
I wish I sat in one
place for nine hours.
I would love that time lapse
because I just
think it's powerful.
It means you're just grinding.
You're doing your thing.
Nine hours of
him negotiating deals
is probably the most
powerful video he could put out.
Nine hours of him on a
speakerphone yelling, right,
yelling against
this wine company,
and that shoe company,
and that sneaker company.
I don't know if
I'm an influence.
I'm like, "Fuck, he
knows what he's doing."
Like, that's what
he's doing, you know.
- [Man 6] And
that's documenting.
- And that's documenting.
That's a documentary
versus a sitcom
where you're trying to
do it at a pretty lake,
or let me go to this carnival,
or I'ma go to the
big football match,
just to show something creative.
That's creating.
And I think when I
started pushing documenting,
it liberated people
because it's hard to create.
It's hard to be creative.
But it's very easy to document.
Most people just
think documenting's boring,
but that's kinda
weirdly the punchline.
I think my biggest failure was
the things that I did not do
because I have so many options.
I mean, big failures.
I can speak about
passing on Uber twice, right?
That's $400 million in cash.
That's life changing,
game changing.
So that's a failure.
But to me, I know it's
something that I don't know.
It's the
conference I didn't speak at
that would've
made me meet Elon Musk,
that would've led to this.
I get so many offers
that it's, The Profit.
Do you guys know
that show on CNBC?
Do they show
that on the internet?
It's a big, big,
business show in America.
I passed on being the guy.
- Oh, to do the host?
- Yeah.
- [Man 6] Why?
- I just didn't think,
I didn't want to do it.
I didn't think it
was going to be good.
So it's all the, you know,
it's all the
things that I didn't do
that are my bigger failures.
("Exjets" by Kwesi)
Hey man, how are ya?
Can you let them know
we're leaving in five minutes?
- Hey there guys.
I'm here with the one, the only,
the hottest
speaker in the world.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Gary Vaynerchuk.
- That's a fun intro.
Hey guys, how are ya?
- Oh my God, Gary, do you know
that you inspired
me to do this vlog?
- Makes me happy, man.
Yeah man, I have
done shit my whole life.
I didn't document, but yeah,
I was going to garage sales,
I was doing baseball card shows.
I worked at the liquor
store every day, every night.
Doing is the only option.
If you're sitting and
watching this man right now,
and you want to be like him,
in the same way he
wanted to be like me,
probably before me he wanted
to be like Casey and others,
there's only one way to do it.
You gotta do it.
Like there's no
pondering, there's no thinking,
there's no tomorrow.
- What about the overthinkers?
- Everybody's an overthinker.
- Everybody thinks too much.
- Why do you
think so few people win?
- Because so few people--
- Why do you think?
- do shit.
- [Gary] Yes! (laughs)
That's right my friend.
Like what do I think
about the overthinkers?
I think they're the market.
I think that's 99% of the world.
That's the punchline.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- You're the best.
- Real pleasure, man.
Real pleasure. (laughs)
- I'm shaking right now.
Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
You're welcome.
(woman laughing)
I love that. It's
kind of cool, actually.
- [Woman 2] In a frame.
- [Man 7] It's framed, yes.
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- I love it. It's gorgeous.
Thank you so much.
You guys are very sweet.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thank you for all your help
at the airport and everything.
- Yes. Thanks.
- I appreciate it. Thank you.
- Thank you.
- All right, bye guys.
- Bye.
- Eleven thirty?
Yeah, that's
gonna be tricky. Later.
And so what is it now?
- [Man 8] The car
is going to a museum
and there are a lot of things,
but it is so huge (mumbles)
they cannot afford to
change all the parts (laughs).
("Exjets" by Kwesi)
- [Gary] Feels appropriate
to be here in People's House.
People's Square in Bucharest.
Huge, huge center built
by the Communist regime.
I'd be lying if I didn't say
every time I'm in this part
of the world there is some
sort of weird, chemical feels
towards the
epicenter of where I'm from.
But it is just a gorgeous city.
These Communist
buildings can get a little dull,
especially when they tore down
all the incredible architecture
that was here originally.
But, just an amazing trip.
An amazing group of people.
Definitely a city that I
want to come back and visit,
and one that I
recommend for others.
Just an enjoyable
trip, DRock. You liked it?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- It was fun, right?
- [DRock] It was great.
- Nice little change of pace.
Miss you guys. See you tomorrow.
Thank you, brother.
I'll see you in the morning?
- Morning.
- 4:30 A.M.?
- Yes.
- Okay.
I'll see you soon.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
- [Gary] Alright, DRock.
We have to get up
in like five minutes.
- Talk to you soon.
- I like you very much.
- [Gary] I like you, too.
We grinded this one.
("Exjets" by Kwesi)